hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to wildlife survivor now
this is a different type of war game and
an interesting concept you or should I
say I am an adorable little bun-bun
that's escaped from a pack of wolves in
the middle of the woods the only way to
get home is to survive the night as a
helpless little bun-bun
you Societe Ron wife of Hagah Walt
that's what I'd assume your lone hungry
and thirsty
you must find food and water rescue the
other bunnies so let us go and hopefully
we'll find some is that ooh yay I ate
little bud Oh little bun applier already
scared oh it's a different perspective
being an adorable little bunny as
adorable as I know I am who is so weird
oh hi is that a wolfy whoo did I run
away who is coming this way
who is coming this way lap lap lap lap
lap lap up some war war hmm I think I
think I drank the whole lake dry oh man
this is the thirsty bun bun Oh bun bun
gonna go in LeWitt's it's such a
different perspective and this is
exactly what I was hoping for it's just
slightly new experience little bun
applier coming through the woods trying
to find other bunnies to make more baby
bunnies I don't know why I've asked my
first priority but you know my head's on
straight so I know what I'm doing I know
what I'm about it seems that I might
have avoided the Wolfie oh man did I
just go into a chasm of doom Oh
hey whoa hey whoa God
hmm I backed myself into a corner I am
like a wild animal because I am a wild
animal oh you wouldn't like me when I'm
angry
who was the beeping was the beeping mean
does that mean is that a bomb
my a bomb bunny oh geez
whoo geez whoo geez Oh God what this is
me just I'm I'm that desperately hungry
that I start beeping maybe I'm thirsty
oh god where am I going
oh geez I need Wawa on my knees wah wah
wah so badly oh geez I'm gonna die Ernie
ah I'm dead
little bunny just flopped over dead no
one even shed a tear for the poor dead
bun bun I didn't even get eaten no one
wanted my corpse after I was dead
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ah so after reading the instructions I
have discovered that I was thirsty so I
need to I was getting plenty of food
lots of noms for the little bun bun but
I need it
that's a Wolfie okay so yeah slurping
slurp slurping there we go that slurping
down in the mug gullet so there's a wool
oh no that's a rock huh mysterious how
that rock looked exactly like a Wolfie
whoo yeah we get one more drink yeah
okay so I was actually right near
another bun bun before I keeled over
from thirst that must have been a weird
experience for that other bun just to
see a fellow bun bun friend and then
have them immediately die in front of me
hmm Oh Nelly okay
I think we're okay eat eat eat eat
little bunny eat little bunny okay I
don't know where I am now I think I'm
lost from from the other bun that I was
gonna find oh oh is that is that the
tired okay so I think this was a chasm
that I entered and I believe I made a
right turn somewhere here oh no I'm so
tired okay so I hit a dead end on okay
this is the dead end so it was just to
the right here little bunny little bunny
foo foo running through the forest holy
[ __ ] I'm gonna die I'm tired okay ah ah
bunny
make babies with me oh I saved a bunny
yeah okay that's good okay I saved a
bunny so super jump I can jump out this
chasm didn't know that did that's not as
super as I thought it was gonna be yeah
yeah oh geez
whoa jeez that's not where I wanted to
be little bunnies going in a circle
someone saved bun applier please I'm
alone and scared okay Wow running
running running through the woods oh my
god that is some intense music holy [ __ ]
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah is anybody know that's a
rock ah [ __ ] I'm dead oh god oh god oh
god okay
think we're okay but I think I'm about
to die of thirst
well that running made me a thirsty bun
bun bun applier needs some water after
having an ear brush with good okay
where's wah wah come on give me my Wawa
please I'm desperate what that red we're
good
Oh No oh I'm gonna die again what a die
of thirst because I'm a failure
ah [ __ ] how's it gonna be my last words
when I actually die
ah [ __ ] then I'm dead it's not funny
it's not joking sit let me give this
another go this time okay so I have a
better idea
I I think there's probably only one
water source and it's probably only this
one so I need to return here often and
then save my running juice for quickly
getting there and back yeah okay so get
you save them yeah alright we're gonna
have a beautiful family once we get out
of here and go to vacation in Maui but
for now we're gonna run for our goddamn
life where's that ding dong ding wah wah
where's wah wah Hey okay oh there is
yeah I'm little bunny drinking taking
sips with my little snuff ler whatever
it was it called [ __ ] I don't know that
the bunny nose [ __ ] piece-of-shit
sniffer [ __ ] that's the technical term
for it found another oh ah that's not
important right now trying to take it
[ __ ] was the [ __ ] name of the
rabbit's nose mouth the whole thing I
don't know
[ __ ] it who cares not important but
applier doesn't need to know what apply
are the best money multiplier don't need
to know deny did anybody oh you want to
be my wife hello okay so apparently the
first way that I went was the only way
the where there was
any more water so I fob or nook my
ownself
oh oh hey oh let's go away forever
goddammit how am I supposed to be able
to find any more bun buns there's four
more am I supposed to be able to find
four more buns I barely see anything in
these woods
how are they surviving but I found you
oh I got three I'm not gonna get all six
there's no way in hell
there's no way in goddamn hell what is
this can i light a fire
what applier needs warmth but applier
needs to seduce all the lady bunnies if
you know what I mean Olo River okay so
bun applier found a river what does that
mean for bun bun
but look glug glug glug also is this
supposed to be snow I didn't even
connect the dots that this might
actually be snow anybody mind over here
ready bun buns gonna super jump across
this huh that was nice jump that's a
quality um if I need to run away from
any Nair do Elle's I know how to do it
jumping and what pray tell is the oh
[ __ ] me okay ah that's not a good sound
I am dead undead Undead wanded ah
bun bun fire fire I got four whoo why
didn't you go after that bun bun instead
of me Oh
super Joe ah that's AK Oh Jo
goddamnit oh man that was terrifying
that's terrifying those horrifying a
little pun appliers heart can't take
that horse being over 200 beats per
minute deadly for a little bun-bun to be
that mean okay so that is what was the
name of this game like wildlife survivor
so I got four of six bunnies which is
way better than I thought that I would
ever do and that game is shockingly
scary because it puts you in the
perspective of something that is
actually helpless not just a guy who
can't fight back a monster you're a
bunny a little itty-bitty bunny and your
little anybody bunny self is gonna get
its ass bit off by the wolves and the
cold and the nature so thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
try this game for yourself down the
description below let me know if you get
all six and let me know if there's a
special ending to play so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]